i called for 9-1 and the lady said sorry
we don't service there
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to
oh my god hi
with me george lopez let's do
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere
what's his name george lopez
welcome everybody to oh my god hi
dude how's it been for you know what
should we just probably probably thank
the people that are
because i think every week the
viewership and listenership
right i believe so thank you everybody
for
listening and watching that's a big deal
you know
of all the things that i think i've done
movies or the show or stand up i think
this
one here is the one that i think is
closer to my
real personal self
and i would say that
a lot of people think that if you become
successful that
maybe you drive a nice car maybe you
live in a nice house
maybe you have you know good better food
better you go to better places you can
afford better places but
does all of that keep you from getting
[ __ ] over by people that you trust
no negative you know you can show
somebody the light
but
you know i just you know i i don't think
that
uh you know you take a guy
and you know remove like you know you
and i've been friends a long time
but also when somebody who doesn't have
two nickels to [ __ ] rub together
things they can [ __ ] with you
that's part of like a whole nother
emotion
you know when people say like oh you
know do you ever think you'll get
remarried
or who are you dating you know you're
you're
you know i don't know if i've if i could
say actually
dated anyone in the last 11 years
but when you're around
somebody who reveals their true self to
you
i don't give a [ __ ] if you live in a
[ __ ] mansion
if you live in a [ __ ] car
when somebody reveals their true self to
you
regardless whether you think that your
life is going to be
worse without them in it get rid of that
person
because if you have someone who is
untrustworthy
who only tells you what you want to hear
but who has a whole other [ __ ] set of
problems that you can't fix
but you won't walk away because it makes
you feel good to think that you can fix
somebody when in reality
you can't and that person is [ __ ]
notoriously
just [ __ ] hurtful for the fact of
hurting somebody
walk away
walk away guys go back you think you can
save somebody you think somebody's gonna
change
you know what i don't think anybody's
gonna change maybe the [ __ ] from
memento that couldn't remember where the
[ __ ] he was
he had to put [ __ ] pictures on his
[ __ ] chest to see what he ate for
breakfast
when someone shows you their real self
and i'm and this isn't like woman
bastion or male bashing
it's [ __ ] soul-bashing because when
someone has a bad [ __ ] soul
and is trying to get over on you and
over on your kindness
but then again behind your back will do
[ __ ] because
they admired somebody or they're a fan
of this or a fan of that
under the disguise of you know i'll
always have love for you they don't have
love for you
love isn't [ __ ] and love isn't
holding hands and love isn't
you know [ __ ] selfies love is like
the [ __ ] that you tell somebody that you
[ __ ] that you demonstrate
not words it's what you demonstrate
somebody can say oh i love you
and they're away from you and then
they're dipping on the side
like that's it was me but also you know
that that's not good man it's not good
for me
and it's not good for anybody else but
in relationships and
latinos they get married you know they
meet somebody [ __ ] twice
and they're already getting a [ __ ]
elks lodge over there and [ __ ] silmar
but it's like you know wait for somebody
better
wait for somebody that doesn't if they
reveal yourself and they're
a better person that you thought then
those are the people that you want you
want around in your life
not somebody who is just in a way
passive aggressive kind of control
to just make you think that somebody who
don't have two nickels to rub together
is a thing that's been missing out of
your life
but why do you think it's like difficult
to to separate yourself i think it's
about a little bit of the ego i think
your ego gets
you know damaged with you know it's like
you know
it's the same thing when when when you
find out somebody's been
unfaithful and then
you want to know the name or the count
it doesn't matter how many
yeah yeah whatever you told you won i
won't believe you what if i told you 10
i won't believe you
what if i told you a hundred i won't
believe you i remember one time there
was a guy
that worked at major league baseball
handsome looking dude am i gonna say
his name handsome and he was dipping on
his old lady his old lady was beautiful
and then
the old lady got a knock on the door and
opened the door and
thought it was like you know that they
were opening up
you know like a [ __ ] rib shack
somebody that's a little bit overweight
hey you know i just wanna i'm gonna
start you know
boiling pork hopefully you can sign this
petition where you don't have a problem
with a smell
this person like i don't think when
somebody dips on somebody or does
whatever it's about looks
i don't think it's about looks because
it's about the way that
somebody makes you feel that the other
person doesn't make you feel right
and a lot of times when you think you
have somebody or you have kids or you
have
a a relationship and then someone wants
to dip out
they're not dipping out because things
are good they're dipping out because
things
maybe are bad and somebody's looking for
some
side attention
but then it's like a thing where
you know when guys or girls would see
somebody like that
and they hurt them and they try to bring
them close to you
because that's what you're familiar with
do you deserve that
what part of you makes you think that
you deserve
to have somebody who don't have two
nickels to rub together
ruin this incredibly well-designed
professional lifestyle what is that
inside of you does it go back to
your mother does it go back to your
father does it go back to maybe
something that you saw
you know i don't think latinos you know
are into almost like self-help because
they'll overhear somebody and they go
hey what did the doctor tell you
oh he told me that when i was growing up
you know my mom wasn't around a lot so
then i do this
and that's why i drink a little bit yeah
[ __ ] yeah me too you know what i [ __ ]
hey
i'm gonna put that one down it's mine
too so one diagnosis
two people but no two people are the
same
oh my god uh but also you have to invest
in your
in your self to know that
you deserve better did i already get the
hook uh no no no not at all
no that that wasn't that at all uh i
have a question though what do you think
is
uh going on in their head the person who
may not have two
nickels rubbed together how are they
trying to
is it uh a premeditated thing to
manipulate
and stay with them or that's just the
way they are you know what i just think
it might be
designed from somebody's looks or it
might be designed from somebody's uh
you know a lot of times uh the people
who have a elevated sense of themselves
are people that it's manufactured to go
to pull
to pull on people to go to get over on
people
so i mean it it all kind of probably
reverts back to
to someone's childhood but
nobody can save someone else with
money and nobody can save someone else
with taking them on a trip or
buying them something or telling them
that there's something
better for them unless they believe it
so then you can go 10 years down the
road and the behavior you saw in the
first two years
is the behavior you see in 10 years and
if it's not you
it'll be someone else and then whenever
somebody tells you what they mean to you
and then they're kind of dipping on the
side and make you feel bad because
you weren't as attentive that shouldn't
be
the excuse for somebody dipping that
person's gonna dip
they would dip anyways and this person
that i'm talking about has
dipped and it's been the same pattern
but it's like when do i get off instead
of
letting that person ride another five
ten years right
you wanna you wanna say like i'm done
and that's it
so is that is that how it ends you go
i'm done that's it or do you think it
i think it would probably be the best
thing for somebody to
finally acknowledge that maybe this is
it or else you're going back into the
same track would you go back in the same
trap
well when you talk about like that of
course you don't want to but sometimes
when you're in it you go
because you think that you maybe you
think you don't deserve
somebody better yeah when you do you
have to remind yourself
i don't deserve somebody to treat me
like this i don't deserve
to feel like this and i don't deserve
for somebody to be
thousands of miles away manipulating you
like a puppet
when they know all the buttons to push
mm-hmm well said
i think so but that's the whole thing
but that's the whole thing of
relationships is
you know going going into
a marriage like guys will know that
i mean what dude wants to get married
hey hey
if you show up and you put this ring on
your finger all your friends will
disappear
and they don't have to do [ __ ] you don't
want to do and everything you like to do
on your own
you won't have to do on your own anymore
because you'll have your wife doing it
with you
and when she doesn't do it with you
she'll be [ __ ] calling you asking you
where the [ __ ] you are wait a minute
all i have to do is walk down this aisle
in the church and put a ring on my
finger and my
[ __ ] whole life changes yep
and that's our marriage counseling
portion of the show
that's right listen man there's a lot of
people out there with the wrong person
and they know it and they're going down
the road
you only live one time
and you can't make time you can't get it
back
and you can't replace good times
with bad memories so it's hard
the hardest thing that you see people do
is is to say you know this person's
not right for me i mean it's all that's
how therapies become this whole
big thing well in the last
20 years we've come across tons of guys
who are
what we would think are with people who
just
just rule them or just make them
miserable what do you what do you
think i mean is it the right answer to
what keeps them there
i should say what keeps them there well
if you're talking about manipulation
like you know you might have somebody
that
you know tells some person what they
want to hear
you know um from from what side the guy
getting
manipulated or because like a lot of
times the guy just like just he's just
so i had a guy i had a i had a guy with
me on the road
married guy um road manager guy
and he was living another life
on the road that i didn't know about
like he had his own issues in his own
double life
while i was on the road with a dude i
had my own issues and you have your own
issues
but that guy who you would not expect
because
he only had one job to do was created an
issue by bringing people that
i didn't know about or getting rooms
i didn't know about or hiding someone
that i didn't know about
and that's kind of not what you want to
do you don't want to have somebody
that's like the right hand person to you
be living a lie or if you say where were
you yesterday i called you oh you know i
went down to get something it's a
[ __ ] lie
somebody's saying they went to the gym
to work out it's a [ __ ] lie so when
someone lies to you
i don't care who they are they're a liar
maybe the truth won't be accepted maybe
if you say to somebody
you know why didn't you you know i
i just didn't want to show up you know
you get [ __ ]
but a lie doesn't make it better a lie
continues
the lie because then all of a sudden now
you're telling somebody something
because you want to not make them upset
or appease them or whatever but it's not
the truth
somebody should be able to take the
truth
if you're in a good relationship with
somebody because that truth will be
almost what's real and the lie will be
the [ __ ] that
like why am i with this person you're
either with a good person
or you're with a not a good person
you're either with somebody
who cares about you or somebody who is
telling you they care about you
and then up here on the side they're
running their own game
yep at some point at some point you're
not in high school anymore like in high
school that yeah you walk into school
you see another dude
walking your girls school and you're
just like you're just like what
what am i what am i doing here but that
hurts when you're in eighth grade
and what about when you're 48 you still
see that [ __ ] yeah
do you think a lot of guys though will
uh not make the move you're saying to
make because
nobody will make the move to cut
somebody out of their life because they
think that they might be able to just
get whatever get some or there won't be
anybody out there
else but yeah do you think it's just
like i don't know for a lack of a better
word laziness
like i don't want to go through all that
i mean if someone if someone continues
to
to uh hurt anybody i don't think that
that's
that's but i mean for a guy to go hey
i'm done but haven't you seen guys are
like that well we've seen
okay guys okay uh
what you don't have to say names what
about your dude
that that drank himself
yeah i mean that guy was he
drank himself to death a good friend of
mine and he was brokenhearted because
his
spouse went out and was all over town
and was not having any kind of
relationship at all and he was hanging
on for dear life
and he did not get every blatant sign
she gave to him that she didn't want to
be with him
but she let him pay her bills and she
let him
do the whole take care of the kids when
she was out whatever she was doing
and this guy this guy killed himself
with alcohol
drank himself to death drank himself to
death broken-hearted guy
died of a broken heart if closest thing
i've ever seen in my life
but everybody and all his friends knew
couldn't get to him we all said it we
all said it
everybody said everybody but but what
keeps someone in there is it is it the
fact that they just
will you say yeah maybe maybe so but
some guys it seems like
i mean not in that case but a lot of a
lot of it just seems like some guys just
don't want to go through all the
[ __ ] that goes along with breaking up
what about
when somebody you know succeeds
in a in something whether it's business
or whatever what do they do they buy
expensive things elon musk come over get
a [ __ ]
throwing a [ __ ] jupiter taking
[ __ ] people with him like
but all of those bad things that might
come out come out drug abuse
you see it in bands they start drinking
and start doing heroin start doing coke
they're out there but they think they're
celebrating but they're really not
they're kind of
yeah maybe you think you don't deserve
your success
so you bring in people that you think
you can fix i'm not a therapist
i'm not trying to fix anybody but
a sense of power is to find somebody
that you consider beneath you
and then seeing what their issues are
and then helping them with their issues
because it makes you feel
like you're doing something good for
somebody
but ultimately it could be you it could
be anybody
yeah they've done it before that's
that's a difficult thing man
it seems like the longer when we we came
across a guy i remember remember
uh he wanted to go to scotland and golf
and his
whole life dream was that he was retired
had things going his way and you said
why don't you do it he's oh the wife
won't have that
and you're like you know here was a guy
that worked his whole life
loved golf we played golf with him by
chance yeah and we're talking about when
when the skyline went to ireland and
and and i always say to somebody hey man
if you love golf
you gotta go because it's just
you know you love god watching the
british open like i remember
seeing the british open in saint andrews
i've ever seen lee trevino play remember
all that stuff
and then you never think that you your
feet would be at that first tee in st
andrews and then calling your name out
and then your name yeah
so i just think that people
i think the hardest thing maybe is to
say no
or to say you know i don't think this is
going to
work out for us yeah and i think you
should go your own way
because that other person might be like
okay but they always want to keep the
door a bit
open because of the manipulation and
they know if they do
or say certain things that the
manipulation will be back on
yeah but i think when you go to get
surgery and you have cancer
they don't leave a little bit of it so
that
they trust that it won't grow because
maybe it said hey i'm not going to grow
they go in there and they take all of it
out yeah and that's the same thing in a
relationship like
don't leave a little bit of bad in your
relationship
take the all the bad out
and it might be difficult it might hurt
but you're better off without
you don't think anybody has gotten
surgery where they had something removed
and they said you know what
i like the way i felt before okay go
back and put a little bit back
in there put half my cuddle back here
even though i know it was
a little i know that it was uh you know
atrophied atrophy cool
do you think uh the type of person that
you started talking about earlier
the uh for lack of a better term doesn't
have two nickels rubbed together
do you think that person if you were to
say
hey uh don't don't talk to me more we're
done do you think they would take that
serious or do you think in the back of
their mind they're like yeah i got this
i'm in there um you know that's a good
question
uh i think they well it depends you know
do you do you gravitate back toward them
yeah maybe you let the dust settle and
then a year later you send a text
message it's got to be
all out or out yeah so you got to be out
you can't be
in and out because all of a sudden 10
years go by and you're still [ __ ]
with the same person that
don't have two niggles put together but
they make you feel inferior
mental by by just their mental game and
physically like going out with other
people
somebody that might be known to as a
couple
and they go with that person you're like
wow man that's
really blatant do you think that's what
they use
disregard as like an equalizer if you
think because
they are at a whatever different
situation than you are
um but i think that people hurt somebody
just to they feel like they'll maybe be
able to keep them
that's my point yeah yeah you're gonna
say i'm better than that person and then
i'm gonna
show you yeah but in the meantime
there's five or six other people
down the road that they because i think
it goes along i don't know if we're
talking too much in code here but
it goes along with like uh when you're
talking with the guy you're working with
on ro
on the road and this person where they
kind of they want to
raise themselves up to a level
that they feel like they are the
conquering
person in that relationship rather than
the person who's being taken care of
kind of thing
you know what i mean it seems like both
of them have that same
same ilk of you know that thought well
they always try to
well you know i mean you've seen it we
go on the road and you have somebody
there they're like oh he doesn't want to
take pictures and say hey man yeah don't
don't yeah
you don't talk for me yeah i got it but
they feel
they feel the power even just being
close to somebody like that yep
where they go i don't know let me you
know let me ask them meanwhile
they got no business in your business
they're just they're speaking for you
and you're not there and that kind of
stuff yeah
interesting does that make sense yeah
and then you end up spending
your one life with somebody who you knew
was not good for you and then you end up
servicing them
the rest of your life but when you
looked at it on a pro and con scale
you've given everything to them
and they really haven't given you that
much
it's not even close but their
manipulation
makes you feel like you can't be without
them
you can that's the thing you get uh
two nickels making you feel like like
that's the person that's just have to be
this is
yeah it's manipulation man yeah
all right all right well here's my
here's my uh remember that you're my one
question yeah what was it
what was it yeah are you seeing anyone
you know is that the timing bed
is nothing no no i think that um
and i think you know you and i spent a
lot of time together you know it's funny
that
that you would draw people that are
deceitful
around you like you there was somebody
working in our
business that i met in the early 90s a a
guy
who i met at a at a i was with george
wallace that's all back
like 91 and i meet this guy
and he says that he's the promoter when
in reality
he's the guy working for the promoter so
the first time i talked to this guy
he lied to me and then
we were from the same hometown chicano
dude
and all of a sudden you're like hey
here's what you kind of do from a
hometown
and you might play golf for a little
while you're talking about 91
and then i think his father died he said
i called him all the time which i didn't
remember
didn't remember that and then all of a
sudden in 2005
i let the other guy go who's living
another life
and my mistake was and here's a lot of
people's mistakes
if you have a prompt a plumbing if you
have a problem with your plumbing
in your house don't hire a [ __ ]
carpenter
who ca who could who says hey you know i
can do plumbing
it's like hire a plumber to do the
plumbing
pay them and let them go but i tried to
make somebody who had
no idea what it was like to be a tour
manager
my tour manager in the times when we
went from theaters
to arenas and then you trust that this
guy has your best
interest but he's been lying to you from
the beginning
and then you don't you don't see it
until
nine years later when that person dies
in new york in the hallway
of the saint regis hotel at four o'clock
in the morning
and then you called me and it's like 4
and i'm like i never answered the phone
in the room
and then you said hey man this dude's
gone what do you mean open the door you
walk by me you're totally white
like what the [ __ ] happened you're like
he's in the hallway
deceased you're like what deceased we
just saw him
literally like less than five hours
earlier
and then he's gone
you open the door you see him working on
him he's gone and we closed the door
we're like what the [ __ ] is going on
i had to make the call to the family had
to make the call to the people in the
business
and then everyone is
in shock that this person would pass and
that lasted about
until monday morning yeah yeah exactly
about four days three then when you call
you call somebody in his family and they
and then i said
hey are you gonna be all right you know
because i know that this dude had these
properties and his old lady's like what
are you talking about he doesn't have
any properties
yeah yeah he does he told me he did this
no no no and then that person says to
you
there's a lot of things you didn't know
about this person and you're like really
like what
like he couldn't tell the truth and
here's a woman who was married to this
guy
who says there's a lot of things you
don't know
like he can't be truthful but she didn't
tell me in 2005
she waits till he dies yeah and i call
to see how they're doing and he says to
me
she says to me there's a lot of things
you don't know
and this guy was a [ __ ] sociopathic
criminal stole
you know at that in that period i was
going through my divorce
and you think you have a guy who's a
brother but he's my [ __ ] devil
with you a [ __ ] devil
father's day we fly
back from a gig private plane i'm living
over there in hollywood
he says hey man i'll go over there and
watch the u.s open with you because the
u.s open always ends on father's day i
said that's
great he comes over but instead of
really
his purpose was to sit with me his
purpose was to go
into my bathroom which he said i got to
use the bathroom you're upstairs you're
going to let them use the bathroom by
your bedroom
and that [ __ ] stole my first
rolex
and like three other watches and he
stole money out of my bag
which only he knew what was what
and if anybody saw us they would think
that
he and i were all three of us were
brothers yeah very much guy was a
[ __ ] criminal sociopath
and everything that he said to us from
the time that i met him in 1991
was a [ __ ] lie
100 percent a [ __ ] lie
and this isn't just this dude there's
like one out of every 25 people are a
sociopath
so if someone is lying to you and they
say
you weren't even there yeah i was and
they weren't
eliminate that person from your life
nobody should ever have to defend
themselves on something that you know is
the truth
and they're trying to tell you you
didn't see that
yeah that's not what you saw rewriting
history
all the time this guy was a [ __ ]
criminal man and everything that i
thought i lost
he took i made me think that i
was neglectful of my ipods or my mom
blank pens
or my [ __ ] cash but in reality
this dude was sticking his pocket
the whole time he was jamming me up
the whole time and he made everybody
believe he was a good guy but in reality
he's a [ __ ] devil the worst person
that i ever had around me
and i would tell him hey man if i find
out you're stealing from me
it'd break my heart because you know
everybody was stealing from me and if
you did it
and he would say i'm not stealing from
you and my therapist said did he ever
look you in the eye
and tell you he wasn't stealing from you
i said no he did not right
he had his he had his eye on his phone
huh
he had a phone that he would pretend to
look at
yeah just as a deterrent
like if you say to me hey george what
time do you think yeah
yep yep it's a it's it's a [ __ ] smoke
screen
yeah yeah right and if you ever ever you
ever uh
confront him like hey man whatever
happened with you'd
be looking straight down and that was a
that was a tell
a complete tell so we're in las vegas
and then we're driving to las vegas
and he's sitting next to me and he's
text he's emailing the people in vegas
saying that i need this room this room
this room and ten
thousand dollars in cash and to give
that due to check for ten thousand
dollars
made out to him because he says i'm
getting the divorce
so you wouldn't want it made out to me
and then you make the check out to him
he'll cash it and give me the money
and he cashed it in i didn't know about
it because
a sociopath will put themselves in the
middle between you and in the answer so
if you say
that time i had i went with kiss to
switzerland and we went to the iwc
and i bought that watch and i brought it
back and i couldn't find it
and then our the guy who did security
said hey i found this watch
and that guy said well give it to me
i'll give it to him
and he met him in hollywood and gave it
to him and he never gave it to me
because he put himself in the middle of
everything like you couldn't talk to me
directly
he'd be like you know what he's busy man
talk to me and then he would
he'd base his decisions on that
and after this all happened we we got we
studied up on
sociopaths which is a trip so and
knowing now that like you said
one out of every 25 people in your life
or a person is a person like that who
you can't trust
at all but if somebody's thinking about
your friends but first of all man if
somebody's lying to you
if they're purposely falsifying their
either their job or their livelihood
or their personality then they got to go
man
yeah they they they dwell on people who
like me you know this guy's like hey
you're from the same hometown you got
problems with
this and he he he stoked that like
like that was where he lived that's
where he could get me
to where i would feel like i was you
know like he and i were closer because
we're from the same
place and the same kind of neglect like
a kinship he kind of has you yeah
yeah yeah and the first bib is like
the tip of the iceberg i mean not just a
little
kind of little looking back at those
little lies
were the tip of the iceberg because he
didn't he'd never tell the truth
never told the truth which was crazy i
didn't realize that
don't ever have anybody around you
especially if you find out they're
telling a lie
stay around you because there's a reason
that they lie
and they're lying to protect themselves
from you finding out
what's truthful
especially when any kind of money is
involved because that
or even in women like they just want to
i'll keep this dude here
and i'll tell him what he wants to hear
all right we good so anyways are you
seeing anyone
back to that just doctors okay
we were looking you up man [ __ ] great
you remember that movie turk182 um
yeah yeah i would think that would mean
something was that in the city it was
yeah that was with uh uh what year was
that was that before you
see it that was a durian i was way
before me yeah yeah
yeah that came out in the 80s and this
guy tagged like
some sports stadium whip you know and
he just he became like a [ __ ] hero
huh yeah it's because when you see
names numerous times and it's so big
it's just
it just gets everybody's attention like
it
it has it moves more than art for some
reason
just name repetitively repetitively
repetitively pedally repetitive
it just becomes engrafted in people's
minds and they'll end up liking it or
hating it
i know what um well george's guest today
is the most prolific
graffiti artist uh in in la probably
history
i would have to say at least the 80s and
90s right you have uh your canvas has
been the golden
gate bridge have been disneyland have
been countless
freeways and overpasses you're in music
videos your
bands have you on their drum set uh
unbelievable daniel ramos
chaka ladies and gentlemen yeah back
then
my my name was really bold and basic and
um everybody that did graffiti hip-hop
style
lettering was connect style and kind of
like
cursive and connect letters and style
letters stylish letters but mine was
just
basic and bold and it had the fattest
cap
that sprayed on the wall like
you know yeah yeah yeah so
how did the how did you get the fattest
cap like it had to be the pain right
yeah no pain or how the way you put your
arms like you
you you you have to hold it a few
few inches back you know what i mean
just just go away so it's just your
style not not the tool you're using it's
just
how you're gonna style so you gotta have
style too you can't just
just yeah you know you have style too
you can't just
be just okay so growing up
chicken scratching growing so growing up
as a chicano kid in boyle heights right
what do you remember like how
far back you had your mom and dad or
what do you where did you live what do
you remember
um i grew up in uh housing projects in
aliso village bow heights
and from the 70s and for what i remember
it was uh
it was deserted by the cops and the
ambulance because my mom called for two
bodies when i was in diapers
and um they started they did
she said sorry we can't pick up the
bodies we pick them next morning white
van pulled up
and there was no police investigation
they actually said no
they said no we'll pick up the bodies
the next morning kids had to go to
school
and see these bodies to go to school it
was just
and when i got shot in my front door
because my brother's getting involved
they couldn't get him
get to him so they shot me in my front
door and hit
my leg um i called for 9-1
and the lady said sorry we don't service
there go
and how old were you um i was already
21.
you're 21. and you get shot and they
said sorry good luck but she said sorry
we don't service there
oh they left us to exterminate ourselves
is what happened you know
yeah i agree um
but my thing was
getting out of that lifestyle like not
trying to i started skating
listen to not trying to get into gangs
you know
and then um also uh when i picked up a
can
and a marker i was like wow this is
amazing i was like no way
oh wow and just to see my name on the
bus is riding around
yeah it was like yeah whoa just randomly
you know
were uh were dudes tagging that time
yeah people were always tagging
there were it was a high school it was a
junior high high school trend
back in late 80s early 90s
it ran it it ruled for about
10 12 years it's a high school trend and
it was
was the cops had no control of the
streets whatsoever
i mean we were out there by the masses
and yeah they were outnumbered
they had little guns and gangs had
bigger guns
they were out there with the knife they
had these
revolvers he had these handguns and
these guys were like
military issues yeah yeah right yeah
and they were using handguns anymore to
a point you know because
the cops wouldn't come they would let a
gun play all day long
so to get away from the bullets i went
riding on the walls you know and
and when i first um started looking at
it was
it was it was a a culture a hit part of
hip-hop culture
west coast graffiti is like gang-related
and
east coast is about expressing yourself
who could do with better style who can
do it better and bigger
and with it came you know break dance
rap but they would do the trains back
east the trains back east and
different colors and stuff yeah it's a
it's a like a triplet cultures the dance
the music and the
and the graffiti the graffiti and now i
mean
you now i've i i was up in bakersfield
about eight years
and um i was doing storefronts a bunch
of storefronts and
for about 10 years i did restaurants and
i got to a point where i can
um paint portraits of people with just
freehand
you know my skills but
the people don't know know me that i get
down that way
they just want to get that that
the ecstatic feeling when they see chaka
named chaka you know
um people would tell me when i got
caught um
that uh they would get on the car
a car load and go look for chakas
like pokemon oh yeah yeah and they would
just go around that's awesome yeah
of course the same thing well i think
that you know
like i'm older than you are so i
remember when i first
started to see stories about you in the
la times
or even maybe see a graffiti that you
did
and no one had ever seen you but then
also knowing that the police were after
you
made you a like a hero man
right yeah made you a hero hold on like
you would just know that
mostly probably done in the middle of
the night we go to the dodger game
and along the five or up on top you'll
see a chaka
yeah and you're like [ __ ] man you did
this last week i was telling you that
i was on western and santa monica and i
look over
there's a some dude like dancing by
himself and i look over
and on the telephone pole is a tag that
said
that said chaka oh that's right
so how many people while you were doing
it though how many people knew
who you were how many people like while
you were in your heyday like in the 80s
how many people
knew you were chaka um
and did they ever try to rat you out
yeah well what happened was it was
that turn of the century or that
breakthrough
it got so overwhelming with graffiti
that um the media
made an example out of me yeah of course
uh yeah i was imagine
and uh
and 24 hours after getting released out
of jail
from doing six months i ride in a
courthouse elevator
hey we can register but supposedly
allegedly well then
that's awesome so my buddy who
i went with uh his white
long blonde he was a hollywood stoner
like in the 80s
and um it was my writing partners these
and he had the marker it was not my
style it was
like a cursive so his name was on top
and then they found the marker on him
and uh a bunch of d.a
showed up he threw us in a court
courtroom uh cops showed up
everything showed up and uh they
couldn't pin it on me so i was
going out the double doors of the court
there was a circus of
pictures cameras microphones at me
did you do it did you do it and they
they told me before
they said don't say nothing don't say
nothing so my buddy is like
there was this one commercial that um uh
uh football players
would say we're going to disneyland yeah
yeah right oh oh
okay and then uh even richard ramirez
used that
yeah he did yeah so
i started laughing and the next day i
came out
on the newspaper with a smile so to
like the
the upright society like down upon that
because that was just
it was like a slap in the face on the
law
right yeah did you disrespecting kind of
like yeah but
it was this guy was cracking jokes so i
didn't like mean to like
like laugh about like what i did you
know
but i didn't do it i didn't do it though
that's a beautiful part yeah homie
didn't
yeah yeah right it wasn't you but not it
it's
done and always you know i mean now i
could say that statue of limitations but
no i'm not snitching
when did you first realize that that it
was getting
to where you were getting some attention
uh because you're probably tagging right
you're not
it came as a swarm i didn't i didn't
know it like the
when i got caught the media blew it up
like instantly
and all over the papers i was in cnn
europe i was everywhere
yeah oh yeah that crazy wow yeah i
had relatives from boston because i was
born in boston
but i came to diapers in east delay wow
so so
wow um that's a trip man yeah i i still
claim east l.a you know
so when you started when you started
started uh
first of all i'd love to ask how old you
were but um when you started uh i'll be
when did you get 249 this year
oh right on so when did you actually get
to your signature
chaka were you just like tagging the tag
or doing crazy stuff when did you get to
like where
i mean what we're looking at right now
and what did you get to chocolate tell
everybody where you got your name
because
oh it's a great story i was like
i started running the streets at very
young young age
um uh six years old
oh [ __ ] six years old in the first grade
i will hop the fence from school
wow and make my way over the l.a river
bridge
into placito vera alvarez street
take lily goods and go sell them
at the projects wow for a bag of
quarters and there was a six years
arcade in the middle of the projects
right there and uh and
well i had actually like a a best friend
i started following he's
he was pretty bad kid so i followed him
he
used he was teaching me the ropes on
everything six as well he
used six as well but he this guy just
knew everything and his brothers
that's crazy his brother was involved in
gangs and he gets um
a hold of a joint no well it looks to be
a
rolled up in the zigzags you know okay
that's right
and he thought it was weed and it
turned in and turned out to be we it was
angel does meant leaves
dipped in pcp a six-year-old did did
angel dust so he he took
he took we hit we did school and we were
behind the bushes
and he pulls up the to his mouth and he
this is how you do it he lights it up
this is how you do it he takes a toke
and then he passes to me and i take
another toke and we pass
out and we didn't wake up till like um
it was night time when we woke up woke
up [ __ ]
six years old that's unbelievable
wow and then later on he gets to hold
the real
the real marijuana joint so and then you
request then you're dialed in there
sometimes they only
were still six so that's a guy who kind
of showed you the ropes on like on the
streets kind of like tagging and stuff
no no the project life
just the mm-hmm um well you you weren't
afraid of that
yeah you weren't you weren't afraid of
night or you to freedom or anything uh
wow i wasn't afraid of death anything
well
happened was maybe um
at um um
you could take yeah
i i can't blame things that happen you
know what i mean it was a dark period
but something happened you know when i
was young
and my mom came back from the store
and and uh my my brother
he was only five and i was four and
there was like a key chain lock on the
door
and he locks it when she comes back in
she was just
pissed or whatever she was going through
and she breaks open the door and she
loses control she blacks out for like
two
three hours and um there's like
blood all over her she hits like
anything she can wire hang is whatever
belt buckles yeah like she lost it and
she woke up i
snapped out of it and called my dad and
my dad to take us
station wagon up to the hospital and uh
and they missed my my brother's juggling
ring got missed
yeah there was punctures
in next right yeah this is the
the doctor had to call the cops we went
to mclaren hall for like maybe
six weeks my mom wanted us back
i mean um
i flunked the first grade all the
messing around and
ditching so um my mom throws
me in the room i still go to school but
i can't come out of the room at all
she feeds me in the room and everything
but my dad was working as a janitor
back then and he brought books from
fifth and sixth grade all kinds of
different subjects
so i started devouring those books oh
yeah yeah i started loving them and
we request more books and so you're
reading at a higher level than you
actually were
exactly right yeah and when
i got to the second grade uh they put me
up in gifted honor
class honor student
wow and i started getting good grades
and having vision that's when i had a
vision that
um when i was locked up in the room for
one year
i know be somebody great and i would be
somebody great
i just something something hit me that i
know i'm gonna be so great
but the topics that that hit me the most
is just like world cultures
geography um history i love history
and you think that that lent to your
style
um my style no my style is more
just expression of myself it's just
especially in myself not
too much of um but you know
um in that time as a young
boy like you're so young man like you
don't
we don't really have the emotional
capability to
understand that maybe anybody loves you
because like that like they're always
beating you
or putting you in the room and stuff
like that so
you know i don't think anybody can come
out of a situation like that
and not have having a a better
unfortunately
a better idea of what's good for them
you know like you wanted to express
yourself
and you devoured those books and you
know
mom had problems my mom had problems
and you almost have
you know now you you see a t-shirt that
says so-and-so against the world but
it doesn't mean anything when you're in
some [ __ ] room and they put you in
there with some books and you can't go
out and
you there's not even the inner there's
there's nothing you're just
in there not then and at that point you
have to think that there's something
better for me out there but but
do do most people find it not really
but it's always good to hear a story of
somebody that
really had no options you know that
when they take you over there take your
mom away your dad comes and gets you and
all that [ __ ] is just
so horrific for a [ __ ] kid to go
through but then
you find a way but it's not even about
pain you just find a way
to express yourself to want to do
something better
that's not jack and [ __ ] out of
that pain
that's not robbing people or making
other people yeah not ganging up yeah
the [ __ ] that you went through you used
it as a former express
if you go through all the [ __ ] art of
bango then go cut his own [ __ ] ear
off
and da vinci they're all [ __ ] [ __ ]
bulldozer [ __ ] drug addicts and
[ __ ]
you know leonardo da vinci was [ __ ]
carving that [ __ ]
yeah they spent 40 [ __ ] years carving
that [ __ ] the statues
would [ __ ] talk to him because he'd
be so [ __ ] high
but some people have it and some people
don't
and some people can can sustain
a [ __ ] brutality and some people
can't
and you're never gonna be somebody
unless
you've paid the dues for someone else
your mom
taking it out on you my mom taking it
out on me
and thinking what the [ __ ] did i do i
didn't do anything
yeah and you're just like you know what
i'm gonna be a famous artist
[ __ ] this [ __ ] man because there is
alternative is no
you go out there you see the police they
won't even come to your [ __ ]
area to collect somebody call the police
they
sorry we don't police that area they
won't pick up a
dead body not a dead body or a shot
person who's just been shot
that's unbelievable lapd
did it that way it was came from up up
higher you know
of course yeah let's be these the the
bottom guys
it comes it's a hierarchy but um
they didn't want us to rise up they
don't want mexican blacks to unite
they don't they they put us against each
other i believe that to be true
hispanics against hispanics
you know what did it mean to you bro to
to to be tagging what did it mean to you
personally
um personally um
i do it for me myself it's something
that i
i i get out of it's not
fame based or see all the hoopla
all the other yeah yeah that it's your
identity
identity and when the fame hit i didn't
like it
because i couldn't do nothing i couldn't
get out the projects
and nobody would come in the project of
course back then but
i would try to get out the projects and
it was just like all these fingers
pointing at me
like just too many eyes on me just
people just
randomly recognize me i would get on the
bus
i'll go over here go over there this is
everywhere people
just stopping me is i had to lay low
no i wanted like with that you know
um i was and yeah i was a hero i was
treated as a hero
in the hood um
well let me let me go back and rewind a
little a little bit
uh me and my mom since made up and she
she had a personal encounter with god
wait a minute wait a minute so
so me and my mom don't talk because a
lot of and then a lot of that
and then my mom's in costa rica my dad's
from costa rica and before she left
12 years ago recrying each other's
shoulders and
we both got on her knees and prayed what
did she say to you
i'm sorry that yeah she was in tears
she was in tears said sorry you know
this and that and turned down she still
tells me to this day
you know and how would you say what was
meant for evil
it's gonna be turned around for good
some is
you always get a negative out of a
positive about a negative
you know and how old were you how i'm
sorry church
how old were you when when this came to
pass when you guys made peace
she left about 20 years ago to costa
rica okay and that bought a house out
there peter falls so you're in your 20s
early 30s um this was uh
like early 30s okay and and you
um you let it go bro you let it
yeah cause if i don't find closure then
that's where you have like
you have trauma underself trauma or
unhealed trauma
a creative disorder but through therapy
or addiction
um do therapy no um
because humans can heal he can't heal
humans
um we don't have the answer there's only
one that has the answer
the man upstairs well done so she came
to you and she said
i'm sorry no he knows like not religious
tradition
won't save us as human institution
was it's the spiritual connection with
god not the
like the rules and regulations part of
it it's like
you know he comes inside and he just you
feel it
and you just feel it that that that
heaviness lift off and
and the feeling of that callousness over
the heart and just
you know all that stoniness and hurt
that's gone into that heart and it just
just rips it out and just like oh you
feel so light and so
peace so much peace so beautiful
let's say that sometimes let's look at
like
let's look at like a this looking like a
dog so dog gets beat by its owner
beat neglected whipped
hole with a [ __ ] chain choked hung
and that dog you go near him and that
dog will [ __ ]
rip you apart and if you show the dog
kindness and you show the dog
love
he will he will turn he'll forg he'll
forgive
the things that were done to him and
he'd be a loving dog
like rescues like they say they know
that somebody rescued them
because they know where their situation
was
like i had this dog that i rescued this
big kind of like a pit bull kind of like
what was he
yeah he's uh pit bull mix but and his
neighbor
this dude get the [ __ ] out of this dog
and
when they went to rescue him the dog had
a police report
because the al the neighbors would
complain about this guy whipping this
[ __ ] dog and when i got him
his tail was between he's a big dog you
think this dog if he wanted to
could [ __ ] attack you and bite you
who knows what's in his heart
but you know what man like this dog was
way more forgiving than
i would have been i haven't talked to my
mom in forever i don't know where she is
but i can tell you right now most likely
i will not talk to her
for the rest of our lives and it's and
it's awful
and then you see this dog and you leave
and he cries
and he is
with you and wants to be with you
and my and even my daughter went over
there my daughter's like
this dog is [ __ ] amazing like you
just wanted to be
loved and i said well you know i can't
keep this dog here
because it's not a big enough place and
i gave him a home
and this dog man is in the best place
that you could think that this
person could be and it's not
me that did it it's
the dog that did it like he wasn't
trying to bite everybody that went next
to him he wasn't trying to
[ __ ] snarl you know if you were
looking to get adopted
if that dog would have been like some
people would be like hey man i can't
have this dog anywhere
but even a pet
will forgive the mistreatment before
a human being does like the [ __ ] that
was done to me i'm 60.
but the [ __ ] that was done to me
i just think it the fact that they make
you feel
insignificant like you don't matter
they tell you and [ __ ] they ignore you
at christmas they've been christmas
presents they don't bring you one
nobody goes to your [ __ ] school
nobody goes to your baseball games
nobody gives up you see all your friends
have their parents there
and their birthdays are celebrated and
there you are
with nobody but unless you
find a way to
express yourself from that i'm not sure
what happens here
you're one of these voters that just
riding up just
jacking fools are getting high on the
side now you
every i don't give a [ __ ] if you're a
artist or a comedian or whatever the
[ __ ] you are
we all have a [ __ ] higher purpose in
in inside of us
and everyone knows everyone does people
will give up it's up to you find it you
can find it right yeah yeah
you can find your higher purpose like i
kind of met like all the dudes that
that i'm still friends with man and
i just felt different than they did man
i just felt like that i didn't
not that i felt better i just felt like
of the [ __ ] that i had endured that
there was
something to that like you in the room
saying hey man you know i'm gonna be an
artist
i never thought i was gonna be an artist
i never thought i was gonna have people
know who i am
but i stuck to my story and my story had
significance like you
the story is important right yeah
and so many crazy stories um
going back um that makes sense to you or
not big are you
no no no i that's why your dad one day
said i'm out
yeah right i think so exactly we had
enough man
that's what happens at some point it's a
that's it it's enough
yeah got to be true to yourself some
level
yeah it's um i mean to me it was like
whatever like happened to me is
like to find closure is forgiveness of
self
forgiving herself one for
um we could beat ourselves in the head
over it
like a hammer you know the the self
condemnation the guilt
and forgiving others whatever happened
to you
and it could be to your parents it could
be through
um somebody killed someone your
relatives getting killed right in front
of you
or but also man like in those days
like all the kids would line up and all
the girls would be on one side of the
boys would be on one side
and if you acted out
then you were almost like a bad person
but but when you're artistic
you're gonna [ __ ] act out you're
gonna do [ __ ] that's not normal you're
an artist
you're gonna do [ __ ] that's not normal
but a lot of times like cartoon told me
one time
that when he was like 13 his friends
would make fun of him because he could
draw
and he didn't want to draw because they
would make fun of them okay but that's
also another way of
of you know there was a guy listen man
there's a guy that i grew up with that
his father was an architect
and i'm not going to say his name lived
across the street from the elementary
school
he had a younger brother had a sister
and his father was an architect
and he was the most timid
dude and this and we're talking about
the late 60s like this dude could draw
the apollo rocket and the lunar module
with a pencil
and it looked like an artist like his
father was an architect
but this dude could make it look like it
was a schematic
of the apollo uh lunar module or the
rocket
and he was a i wouldn't say it was a
tough guy
so i run into a cousin of his because i
go to the elementary school
and the cousin comes over and says do
you remember
this person and i said yeah he lived
right there as far as architect
where is he kill some dude oh because he
was being bullied
and he [ __ ] said i've had enough and
he killed somebody
and he's in prison for the rest of his
life and this was the last person that
you think
would hurt anybody but he couldn't take
it anymore he couldn't take the abuse
couldn't take the the bullying and he
killed somebody
and here's this guy who was a beautiful
young kid drawing
the last person you would think that
would be put away
but also how come because i think
everybody thought
everything was cool and you get bullied
and he snapped
could be you could be me could be you
yeah
and this dude just one decision i'm sure
he's in there every you know everybody
makes those decisions man you're just
like
you can't you can't bring it back the
way i
i i wanna um
i'm transitioning to into the art
gallery world
yeah yeah that's great
statue of limitations i recently made a
comeback
like three years ago and
um i was steaming out and i found later
on in
in life you know that it's a therapeutic
outlet for me
you know city property not
not businesses not businesses you know
but
but there's a transition and what i want
not only just to express my art in our
gallery world
but uh giving back to the community
yeah oh effectively at-risk youth to
speak in juvenile halls it's a
motivational speaker
and if i'm uh pumped him up to try to
get them out of the lifestyle
or or enlighten them out of out of that
lifestyle not try but enlighten them i
have that lifestyle
um i can't be i can't be
i can't be doing doing any
no no you're going you're done you've
done it you've done it no i've done my
mark
i i can't try to make my mark anymore
because
eventually you're not invisible
everybody has their day and if you're
doing a crime you're going to get
you're going to get you know what i i
mean i think you would be
this is the name of the game eventually
you go 20 years get away with it you
know but
i think you'd be disappointed in
yourself if after all this time
you got pop for the [ __ ] that you were
doing 20 years ago
because now you want to go legit art
you want to do legit art legit and also
give back to the community
yeah that's what i'm saying but also if
you're tagging it's almost like you're a
bit of stuck in the
where you but you have a presence you
have an identity
that it's it's it's tricky to go forward
because people be like hey well how did
you know why did you do
but also if you stay back in it you're
staying in the past
but wanting to get back to the community
and wanting to tell kids
or somebody listen if you're artistic
you don't have to do what i did
find your own artistic way do your thing
write a journal writer
just paint do whatever i um i taught
a um a three-month curriculum in
bakersfield wow
biggest fields is um it's one of the
armpits of california
so yeah it's a lot of homicides
there's a lot of cops the cops let them
get 20 deep out there
all night and the cops won't don't break
it up wow
in daylight they're running up to cars
and serving dope
like it's just like like the 80s over
there
stuck in the 80s over there
check out the third flower
[ __ ] white roses
yeah right i know i know
because
but also now with uh
you can change the shape of of like
kids that they don't have to do all the
[ __ ] that we did they don't have to make
the mistakes
that we made in order to get
show themselves or or get themselves
seen or heard or express themselves
and not in [ __ ] tick tock like my
daughter [ __ ] dancing
i mean something important to them right
like your voice was important to you my
voice was important to me
and then we all end up in the same and
we all end up in the same place
right nobody's here
by accident like you and i when i when i
hit you up
and then when you and i started talking
i think this is maybe the
first time we met in person
but i knew what you were doing
when you were doing it and i was trying
to do my thing back in that time and
reading the l.a times
and seeing you and seeing the stories of
them trying to get you
for me you know that's why everybody
watched bonnie and clyde al capone
[ __ ] died in 19 [ __ ] what 50s
and people still they revere and they
write stories about those dudes because
they were they were a little bit
dangerous man yeah
you know yeah the artist is the person
that's unlike everybody else
yeah i think you don't fall for the same
right what about the bad news bears the
one dude that could [ __ ] play with
about the ride on the motorcycle around
beating everybody up there kelly
so so that that brings me to a question
i've been dying to ask you i mean you
have to have a million
stories of them like on you almost ready
to catch you and you got away
i mean for years right i mean uh there
had been times it was close calls where
they should have got you and they didn't
kind of thing
oh no they lit they lit a case build up
on me
they started following me out of my
house because oh they let you do it so
they could get you yeah
so they're just eyeballing you the whole
thing you think you're only
getting one [ __ ] you're getting 100.
there's no what happened was i was
catching tags on a notebook
and doing bubble letters and stuff like
a notebook and
when my teachers seen it and your team
you reported me to the school police
you got to be kidding me school police
reported to
to uh holland back division in bowl
heights
so your teacher recognized on your
notebook
that you could be chaka yeah that's
crazy to me
and and i gave you guys
[Laughter]
that's awesome so um
i got interrogated by both school police
and they sent me
and you're a teenager and i'm a teenager
and the investigator in lapd
already had like this photo album this
thick photo album
bunch of pictures like numerous pictures
it was like
all over but i denied every single one
of them
but that sent um um
an entourage or just uh different
cars nice cars and white
people and the projects didn't exist
back then
right so they were parked right in front
of my house and as soon as i take off
i would catch the bus and i would get
off the bus somewhere
far down and uh it was still there
it's still there catching next but it
was still there but i would lose them i
know i don't know
i'll go into the freeways and start
walking freeze
all the way down a couple miles on the
freeway
or did you feel like you were just you
did you feel lonely or you felt like you
were i was always alone oh no kidding
when i did it
you felt like you were alone or you felt
like you were just with you like i'm all
right
better by myself wow i don't know how i
had that so much
you know what i mean like i know because
because it was a drive-by period too
yeah i was doing it in the drive-by
period oh wow
and this the cops had no control at all
right everything was just
is free may him in the streets
crazy so i don't know
like i could have got shot so many times
oh
uh so yeah you could have got [ __ ] up
one time one time
over by on one time over by in east l.a
like past indiana like way deep in east
l.a
and um and there's
six guys that come out around the corner
and gang members they see me riding on
the wall i say chaka
come here and i recognize boys from like
high school somewhere he's like maybe
my classmate and um
i didn't run he go don't run so
one panzone a big belly dude just comes
running and he
pounces me with his belly just goes like
this
and he lands with his belly on top of me
and i'm on the floor
and they're all like no get off him get
off him that's daniel get off of him
i know he's not daniel i know him so i
get up and once talking to me was like
what should we do should we get his cans
or write a block right here do a block
right here in the wall
so i say hey man i'll get down i i i got
some skills
you know on the wall so i started
getting on some gang blocks you know
boom boom boom boom boom finish them and
uh
the the the big belly dude snatches the
can out of my hand he starts riding the
wall and the other guys are like
come around the corner smoke will join
with us man it's cool
don't trip don't be scared and
i came over and a guy comes from a wrong
block
to us and around the house is hey they
caught homeboy he was riding on the wall
and they're taking him to jail so the
one that
got me with his big belly
it's awesome
he didn't do anything right he
my writing partner mm-hmm and uh that
white boy
and we're in broad daylight
catching tags out in the west side like
from mccarthy park area
um and uh it's hella active over there
and we've seen two after our sleaze cut
attack
two of them started running towards us
from across the sea
across the street and uh their arm both
armed
and uh so this was like should we run
should we run i was like no don't run
because they'll take aim and shoot just
talk to them let me handle this
and when they came like approached us
they had guns pointed
at us and i said they were like where
are you from
i said i'm chaka nah
and they both looked at each other and
jaws dropped and said let me see
right there on the wall right now and he
pointed with his gun towards the wall
and i wrote my name goddamn and uh they
said
nah hey man oh it is chaka
and their whole face is went from
monster look to
to just glowing smiles we were just
talking about that
if if a cop caught you and he found out
who you were with they'd be like ah
some might be fair yeah yeah some cats
might be fans too
it's you know it's culture it's like
it's been around
it's not it won't be eradicated
please tell us about chaka it's long
live culture
please tell us about it now it's global
it's like where chaka came from
um chaka i was um
i was back in the i was already a stoner
like long-haired metal
rock and roll oh running lit with vans
and torn levi's at the knees and jerseys
like punk yeah nah yeah but this is like
late seventies oh so it's a metal family
yeah zeppelin dude yeah yeah
and um i i had
hair passed down the shoulders with an
earring already at six years old you
know
like
[Music]
i think there was a [ __ ] six-year-old
kid that could [ __ ] both of us up here
oh he would have to beat my ass
the little six-year-old kid kicked your
ass the police coming to the screen
no not really because that's the best
part not really because
in atlanta the last tv series yeah
really tv series in the 70s it was a
little [ __ ] changing there was a cave
boy called
chaka yeah in the midst of prehistoric
dinosaur land the land of the lost and
these these three humans said his dad
and
what a girl and a boy yeah uh
yeah a dad yeah okay they were
in the raft down in the river and they
went into a cave and went into this
portal
that lighted them and they were going
like that yeah it's all cheesy every
time you watch the same thing
marshall routine expedition
on the greedies oh well done
that's beautiful ah how did you tear in
my eye any time it went down
i was like somebody save them no but
yeah
i kind of fitted that character i fitted
that that character because
i had pushy long hair ah right on but a
big fort hit in so short
and i was friendly to to all the
monsters around her you know i mean
and i could say now that i'm not a
cold-hearted monster no
you know i mean no you're not i'm not
about
doing evil yeah like it's just not right
because it's going to come back to you
seventh full
and it won't be pretty so it came from
land of the lost it's a trip
it's funny how you know somebody ends up
doing
what they're doing and becomes iconic of
that
world you know of tagging and
of expression and artist you know
and it's just becomes uh it's a global
phenomenon it's not
la it's not new york this is a
artistic graffiti has its place around
the world
not just in in la or new york
yeah now it's um to spread the media
just like how um like boulevard nights
and colors and
like it helps spread the
that culture and
help it spread more um pbs
came out in 1982 with a documentary
called star wars
and it was all about the graffiti
culture
the the soviet art culture and
um just vocabulary's terms and
the styles and beef and they went into
like
it's like like like the whole
bible it's i call it the graffiti bible
oh wow
well wow that's the graffiti bible
actually it's funny because
i'm not sure if i'm a fan of nirvana
of the music i like the music i don't i
don't know every song i don't know every
album
i know the kind of situation but i i
love the
i love stories of people like i met dave
grohl a couple times good dude we did
the
we did the grammy announcements with amy
winehouse and i'm like everybody
somebody wake her up
let her know what you want uh and you
know then she dies and everybody's like
hey she was alive when i made those
jokes so much
so you know but
smells like team spirit the video is
an iconic video it was
the band of grunge like if you say
pearl jam or some garden allison change
all great
but do they have a video like
smells like teen spirit in the gym with
the guy mopping the girls all dancing
and dave grohl
saw chaka on the way
from california to seattle
and put it on his bass drum and
on the video it says chaka
it's pretty [ __ ] amazing dude
it's pretty amazing yeah that a guy like
that
who interprets his own art to the base
through the drums to the
guitar would see your name
and say i want this on my on the on my
drums
right now yeah i was blown away i was
blown away i was in
in jail at that time um the inmates i
was taking a nap
in my bunk and there was like 120
inmates in one dorm
it was a maximum security and
they ran woke me up and like it was
going coming out on mtv
all right and they woke me up and they
they carried me nearly to the tv and
said look wow oh that's awesome
all the inmates were like right exactly
right you're like the guy yeah you're
running the showdown you're the man
you're the boss that's awesome
like i didn't i but i mean
yeah and how do i feel about it
uh you know what man you it is what it
is in his destiny
yeah you did what you did and he saw it
and and he did what he did
but you know it's been a name that i've
known forever now
arsenal hall um came out
it's not it's not in video somebody
somebody has an archive but um he came
out
saying joking about me that guy got tags
on everything
he tagged the space shuttle and they
actually show the space shuttle going
to the chocolate tank
yeah we were looking at the uh they have
matchbox cars and stuff like with
chocolates new york police department
and then in living color also use uh
alright
and uh skit with like they were
uh pretend me the honeymooners and the
guy comes
the big guy comes in and goes honey
the subway's so tagged up i i sat down
and
they zoom in on his butt and this is a
chalk on his butt
he got his ass got tagged that's
hilarious
yeah well so tell us about your solo art
show now
so now is that the same kind of art or
as a
departure but so the the art show
pretty much is like you know
it all the tag rules the tag rules so
pretty much i can get down with like
illustration
and art and fine art well it is fine art
yeah it is fine art because you can
never define
art it can be three ugly strokes
right and to someone that is art yeah
good point
wow so um my tag is art
of course style with it big time tag so
the way i would do it is pretty much
like catch the tag
multiple times with like
variation of colors and how do you feel
with yourself
like these days like me i'm i turned 60
yeah i'm contributing
like you know i feel different than i
did at 50 at 40 and i'm almost you know
i think
just naturally almost like looking
to the end looking to the end of
you know doing stand-up and to the end
of of
working as hard and almost a little bit
toward a little bit toward retirement
dude like where do you where do you
how do you see yourself in the next you
know let's say 10 years
what do you see yourself doing i'm still
young
um my great-grandparents
both on both sides of the family yeah
they lived to be over 100
yeah well get your parents my
grandparents lives to be
both on both sides of the penalty to be
over 100.
um wow my dad's pushing an 86.
so he's a just a [ __ ] team my mom and
my mom and he's still
chopping wood in costa rica he's
chopping wow he's growing
there's mango trees he's cooking he's
bought acres over there
you know so he's he has all these
like vegetation going on the tomatoes
onions
you name it no right now he's doing good
he's
his health is good all right trust me
only with all the drugs i've done thank
god i'd recover but
you know yeah me too
well
this boundaries you know i mean you know
i'm going to destroy yourself because
i've done thrown myself away
over the years you know i went to prison
um
in nevada i went to prison nevada
um they dropped two robberies down to
a burglary attempt burglary and uh
well listen man whatever whatever we're
all looking for
and whatever however we do what we do
with ourselves
um you learn from your mistakes
and along the way you start to leave
some things behind you start to leave
people behind you start to leave some
behavior behind
but you know we come in alone and we go
out alone
and it's like what do you learn
the closer to the end is probably not to
be your own worst enemy
not to fall into the same traps you know
fine for 20 30 years ago but you don't
want to be
at our age and still make
mistakes i don't think you can be a og
and be making mistakes that you should
have learned from [ __ ] 20 years ago
it's the [ __ ] to not make the mistakes
and continue to go forward and do
you know and do whatever we do that
makes people happy man
you know right yeah
yeah to
um it is a uh
kind of a lot on my plate you know what
i mean yeah to be nikon
yeah yeah and keep a role model good
role model you know what i mean
um you want to leave a legacy legacy
behind
you know what i mean when you die you
know what i mean
you're going down to the books i'm going
on the books
everybody has a great conning calling on
our life
everybody has a great destiny but you
have to discover yourself find yourself
first
find closures within yourself um
open up to to to people
of greater like great people um
surround yourself with great people
we're really great people with good
people
you know people that are for you and not
against you
you know um you're not chosen to be
mediocre nobody's chosen to be mediocre
you're chosen to be history maker
you know and you gotta find that in you
beautiful and uh i have to ask you how
many in your opinion because there's a
lot of different numbers out there how
many
pieces do you have around the world do
you think
um what's the furthest place you tagged
new york area there's video of you doing
a new york
police department car yeah that then it
became a toy
with a signature on it yeah yeah how
great is that
a statue of limitations that was over
three years that's the limitations
felonies technically is three years yeah
especially musicians this is well over
three years so yes i can admit and then
i'm trying to get you to come over to
the restaurant and tag the restaurant
that would be great opening day happy
very fifth i'm trying to get him to come
down and
on camera tag the restaurant with
legally
open arms so how many do you think but
yeah eventually
ultimately where i want to take the
direction i really want to take
when i'm older a lot older is
you know i still want to go to school
get teaching credentials yeah and teach
kids you don't want me to teach kids no
that's great bart
but at-risk youth and the gangs get a
hold of them
by the time they're 13. in these
really bad areas you know what man i
think that's a great i think that's a
good look
so night classes would be from like from
eight
from eight to twelve
ages from eight to twelve before the
gangs get hold of them
because they're they're they're gone by
the time but you know what man
there's very few people like you like me
that people can learn from as an example
of somebody who looks like them
and i think that's a good thing for you
man i did i did something here in
bakersfield
um back in 2000
wow 2012
um i i did a curriculum
of 90 days the first nine days
is was not spray paint was on paper
and they were the ones that weren't
artistically
they believed were not artistic inclined
you have to speak
life instance to wake that up and pull
that treasure out for them to discover
it
and it's you got to feel it's passion
passion wakes everything up right you
know and you don't have to be artistic
and claim but
believe me if you put heart to it it's
going to come out
and it's just basic shapes from circles
boxes doing stars
you know i drew a better one i drew a
better gun on a guy's 40th anniversary
party
i was still trying to live that one down
there there won't be no curriculum with
that one
but not only no these are like some
like in bad areas you know what i mean
but um they also got a clean
they also got you know how to treat each
other and stuff like that you know what
i mean
but not not like not liking as a in the
form of a parent
or or as an authority figure but as a
friend
right you know what i mean that's
mentorship as
mentor a mentor a real mentor is
somebody that doesn't come
as a parent or as an authority figure
right
by them well thank you so much for being
here uh i
i am noticing a little pain on your
fingers what if what
were you just just working on like oh um
oh or did you get maybe you've got maybe
got all things coming
hold on hold on oh yeah um
may 8th is false and saturday
the second saturday um by will street in
fairfax by the museum yeah
um doing a pop-up show oh [ __ ]
amazing
all right come on that's amazing so
um stay tuned in instagram
my instagram is infamous bottom slash
chaka yep infamous choco
well and stay tuned there for date and
time it will be on the saturday may 8th
from 5 00 to 8 p.m
beautiful thank you so much for being
here thanks for watching
thank you man thanks for that daniel
ramos chaka
all right what did you say that are you
married to a latina you think you throw
a little [ __ ]
no i didn't i didn't ramos said i went
ramos
your name was raymond yeah yeah yeah
he's dan raymond
danny
[Laughter]
with a [ __ ] dick in the [ __ ] you
enter your spoon
they're magically delicious
you